breaking huge news I heard about this
must have been about 11 30 or 11 45 last
night we've had this building scandal
over Donald Trump national security
adviser Michael Flynn's connections to
Russia he has now resigned just weeks
into the donald trump administration
it's interesting that all the records
Trump is setting are not good records he
reached fifty percent disapproval in
something like eight days something that
had taken other presidents hundreds or
even over a thousand days to reach in
the past and now Donald Trump's national
security security adviser lasted only I
guess 24 days being februari 14th today
this is scandal time folks I know that
Fox News and Drudge Report and alex
jones and and people in Trump's staff
like Kellyanne Conway are all going to
play it down Trump's cronies will play
it down but this is huge let me give you
the background in case you didn't follow
the story there were weeks of
speculation over the links to Russia up
for national security adviser michael
Flynn and in the last few days it ramped
up even more up specifically because of
the content of Michael Flynn's calls
with the Russian ambassador and
transcripts of intercepted calls between
Flynn and the Russian ambassador to the
US Sergei kiss Liev showed that they
discuss sanctions before Donald Trump
was inaugurated so this is problematic
for a number of reasons number one Flynn
was at the time a transition team member
for a president elect right not the
President and he had conversations about
Russian sanctions with an ambassador
totally unethical it violates the one
president policy which is there is one
president there is only one president
and that President administration are
the only ones that should be having
these types of discussions but beyond
that as usual it's not just the problem
itself but it's the cover-up and michael
Flynn denied having had those
conversations with the Russian
ambassador as a result Mike Pence the
vice president stuck his neck out in an
interview saying oh no Flynn and the
Ambassador did not talk about sanctions
it became clear that those were lies and
indeed Michael
Flynn admits that in the resignation
letter where he says quote unfortunately
because of the fast pace of events I
inadvertently brief to the vice
president-elect and others with
incomplete information was an incomplete
it was wrong he goes on to say regarding
my phone calls with the Russian
ambassador I have sincerely apologized
to the president and the vice-president
and they have accepted my apology but
but Pat Hillary's emails and then Ghazi
and Obama would have done the same thing
right well it was funny initially you
saw michael Flynn deny these allegations
but then the Washington Post pointed out
that nine US intelligence officials said
that he did so the administration said
well we can't say with a hundred percent
certainty either way I think the writing
was on the wall yeah after nine agencies
said that when was lying the
administration said we're now only 99
percent sure that Flynn is telling the
truth it's time to panic Paul Manafort
step down from Donald Trump's team
because of Russia connections michael
Flynn is stepping down because of a
Russia debacle Russia has a trump
blackmail file parts of which we've now
learned are true and nobody is concerned
yet Kellyanne Conway eight hours before
Flinn resigned told MSNBC that when had
the full confidence of the President
that's fake news right or did she really
not know that this was a problem I'm
sure she didn't know I mean it's funny
how Donald Trump values loyalty above
all else but then one of one of his
subordinates it turns out that they have
a scandal in their past like chris
Christie or Paul Manafort yeah he drops
him like a bad habit the White House was
warned about this and that the Russians
might be able to blackmail Flynn last
month we've also learned Flint Flynn
rather went on a paid trip to Russia
celebrating Russia today with sitting
next to Putin you really can't make this
stuff up we know that hacking was
directed by Russia to help Donald Trump
win the presidential election Trump
advisor Carter page is under
investigation for his ties to Russia
he's continued to visit Moscow in spite
of the investigate
the Secretary of State the former Exxon
CEO Rex Tillerson he pops up turns out
he has extensive ties to Russian oil he
lobbied to reduce sanctions on Russia he
was awarded the Russian order of
friendship honor by Vladimir Putin this
is scandal of the highest level and it
was all completely predictable every
single one of our fears about Donald
Trump and Russia is slowly coming true
the trumpets seem to be in some kind of
paradise Trump's former campaign manager
was a Russian puppet Trump national
security advisor appears to have been
very much compromised by Russia Russia
has a blackmail file on Trump but we're
supposed to believe that there's no
concerns over Trump himself it's all
becoming completely unbelievable Pat but
I think that there are still Russian
rather trumpets who at least officially
are saying they're not at all worried
about anything that's going on I think
those people who are still with them
will stick to them to the very end even
if he's impeached over some of these
Russia connections he could should be
two people on Fifth Avenue and he would
still have the support of individuals I
don't think some Russia corruption is
going to have a really big impact this
is a scandal don't let anyone like
Kellyanne Conway convince you otherwise
just 24 days into this administration we
already have at least one major scandal
and a number of smaller scandals more
than President Barack Obama had in eight
years as president